we're going to turn now to other news
including the January 6 investigation of
former president Donald Trump a landmark
ruling a judge's ordered that former
vice president Mike Pence will testify
will need to rather before a grand jury
will need to testify about Trump's
efforts to overturn the 2020 election as
Robert Costa reports this is something
that both men wanted to avoid
in a ruling that could have historic
consequences former vice president Mike
Pence has been ordered to testify before
special counsel Jack Smith's grand jury
on January 6 about any illegal acts
committed by former president Donald
Trump I have nothing to hide I have a
constitution to uphold I I upheld the
constitution on January 6th the decision
is a major blow to Trump's legal team
with the judge ruling executive
privilege does not apply and that
private exchanges between Trump and
Pence are not off limits they're looking
for evidence of criminality if the
former president in connection with
overthrowing
our election
and there's nothing more important than
that and there's no witness probably
more important than the former
president's own vice president Pence has
long argued he shouldn't have to testify
because of his constitutional role in
the legislative branch the notion of
compelling of former vice president to
appear in court to testify
against the president with whom they
served
is unprecedented but I also believe it's
unconstitutional the votes for president
of the United States are as follows but
the judge ruled Pence will not have to
discuss topics that deal specifically
with his role in Congress on January 6
and last night Penn said he and his
lawyers are still deciding whether to
appeal we're currently speaking to our
attorneys about the proper way forward
sources close to the investigation tell
CBS News Pence's one-on-one
conversations with Trump in the Oval
Office on January 5th 2021 the eve of
the Insurrection are of high interest to
prosecutors since Trump then was
enthralled by the Gathering mob outside
and eager to pressure Pence to do his
bidding and Bob we're also waiting for
more information on the Manhattan grand
jury investigation tied to these hush
money payments to Stormy Daniels what's
the latest on that the grand jury heard
from an additional witness on Monday but
based on our reporting it might not meet
now for the rest of this week prolonging
a decision on a possible Trump
indictment wow and then we got Easter we
got Passover we got school breaks it
seems like it's getting pushed down the
field TBD yeah Bob thanks Bob